[Applaudissements]
les 20h14 sera jusqu à 20h29 c'est
facile quatorze +15 égale 29 mois on a
plus de lumière ça y est c'est sûr ça
n'a pas payé électricité faut nous le
dire
on a du nouveau à propos du concours
miss france a aujourd'hui miss aquitaine
s'est expliqué sur la polémique du
nichon gates et oui regardez on va tout
vous expliquer et ça prend il faut
envoyer le chrono 1
ça prend une ampleur aulas l'a regardé
samedi soir sur tf1 en direct de
l'inesss et miss tahiti qui était
couronnée miss france devant plus de 7
millions de fidèles et durant la soirée
un court passage a beaucoup fait parler
les internautes et choqué certains
téléspectateurs il s'agit d'un plan de
quelques secondes un caméraman de tf1
s'est égaré en coulisses il voulait sans
doute faire un plan artistique
il aura fait malgré lui un plan érotique
et c'est la pauvre miss aquitaine qui a
été victime de cette bourde une mauvaise
soirée car déjà en début d'émission
c'est elle que sylvie tellier avait
confondu avec miss auvergne
au lendemain de la séquence sylvie
tellier s'est justifié sur ce passage
dans le 13 heures de jean pierre pernaut
voulais m'excuser auprès de la
production très les candidats
contrepartie n'a été dévoilée ça aurait
pas dû se passer sur une grosse erreur
de notre part eckart l'abonné ceux-là
miss en question s'est elle aussi
exprimée au sujet de cet incident qui
depuis samedi n'en finit plus de faire
parler
je n'étais pas un truc mais déjà c'est
un acte usant malgré ça tf1 n'a pas su
gérer leur caméra
ce n'était pas du tout professionnelle
et sincèrement les commentaires d'un
faire je m'en fiche
cela me passe au dessus alors selon vous
tf1 at-elle commis une faute
professionnelle
alors c'est vrai qu'elle est très
remonté je vous le dis et elle veut
absolument faire un recours au csa
sachez le cette jeune fille alors est ce
que tf1 a commis une faute
professionnelle
vous dites non ici ça dit plutôt no easy
cd plutôt oui alors matthieu delormeau
vous dit non non je dis non voilà c'est
une erreur c'est une erreur ça peut
arriver parfois ils ont mis une caméra
ils se sont excusés
je suis pas fan aussi utile il faut
parfois un peu dur elle s'est excusé
platement elle est venue le faire dans
un gie alors justement regardez vous
voulez vous regarde elle est venue là
elle est venue au jt de tf1 de créateurs
pour s'expliquer on va voir ça puisque
tu en parles tout de suite exactement et
bien ce spectacle de service était un
très grand cru de miss france et des
costumes les chorégraphies magnifique
avec un petit quoi quand même mais bon
un gros couac en coulisses et d'ailleurs
je voulais m'excuser auprès de la
production près des candidates dont
cette intimité a été dévoilé ça aurait
pas dû se passer c'est une grosse erreur
de notre part et c'est un petit peu
gâchée sochaux qui a été suivi par plus
d'un million de personnes
les chorégraphes été superbe les
costumes on a une équipe de production
une productrice des fermes où l'équipe
en face
oui mais là il a mis sur question est
très très très joli ça n'a pas toujours
dire elle est très jolie chanson petit
shoot derrière a elle en revanche c'est
plutôt maladroit parfois elle a été la
pauvre elle apparaît donc en rien sp
chasse psp interpellé partout sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'elle arrêtait
derrière elle en subit les conséquences
la pauvre là vous pouvez pas dire ça
c'est pas une catastrophe mais c'est
bien quand tu dois quitter ton à tout va
mais c'est pas le cas tout le monde
soupire viens trois secondes sur terre
encore une fois en europe en étant 2018
aujourd'hui tous prendre nos pur
incroyable on a vu un bout de sein
malheureux se sont excusés jusqu'à
catastrophe à partir du moment où elle
elle le vit mal
moi je pense clairement que c'est une
faute professionnelle et je pense
surtout que tf1 nous pisse dessus et
nous fait croire qu'il en bleu il rapide
de truites avaient conquis c'était un
gars qui savait bien que sa démarche ait
l'impression qu'on nous explique qu'ils
l'ont pas fait exprès non je suis désolé
une caméra qui filme dessin généralement
elle le fait exprès ils sont pas nous
prendre
on est le réalisateur
je termine simplement ma phrase je ne
mets pas ça sur le réalisateur je pense
que tf1 a sciemment mis une caméra dans
les coulisses on le fait les consignes
des configs mode et ça on l'a faire
consciemment alors ben non il a évoqué
spécialiste des boiteries oui ils l'ont
fait d'abord l'année dernière il n'y
avait pas eu un seul couac
elle ne l'a pas minimiser puisque quand
jean pierre pernaut lui dit c'est un
petit coin kalliste un gros couac c'est
normal que la jeune miss
évidemment elle en met une couche parce
que c'est normal qu'elle a été heurtée
mais en revanche on peut pas dire que ça
a été fait sciemment puisqu'ils l'ont
fait à la répétition à la répétition ça
s'était très bien passé oui et donc là
il se tait la république à l'âge et le
manga a expliqué en disant on a boosté
mon caméraman à un moment il a été
bousculé donc j'ai perdu quelques
nanosecondes quelques petites secondes
ce qui fait que j'ai gelé mis à
l'antenne au moment où il ya eu un bain
voilà barça remercie quand tu utilises
tu étais choqué tôt non je suis pas
choqué mais après rien qu'elle a dit que
la lada maladie qui est clairement que
c'était de leur faute mais après c'est
pas grave on verrait pas à s'excuser
après beaucoup y voient là elle fait non
c'est sûr tous ces noms mais voilà c'est
donc voilà c'est dit alors gilles vers
nous c'est pour moi très grave
la banque sur l'honneur d'une femme qui
a été jeté en pâture aux chiens et je ne
suis pas pris oui ça vu que magali vers
d'affaires bio manier deux minutes
elle va voir hélas du mal à s'en
remettre
et selon les informations il ya beaucoup
ya quand même énormément de rififi
effecté loulon je pense que tf1 assumer
en amont le risque du sein nu le risque
d'une niche onglet d'oqtf a essuyé leur
inutilité surcoût de risque pas de voir
ni darlas sur ce plan a pas moins
directe des tarifs sol et saluera lhc
bon merci à les jeux non c'est bon non
mais on est dans une autre dimension là
on est absolument délirants comme
d'habitude je ne veux absolument pas au
complot du niveau de vie et shanghaï
mais non gilles c'est pas une caméra
cachée
c'est une erreur c'est une maladresse à
la fin mea culpa net et sans bavure oui
c'est passé comme un canton des grisons
st michel mais oui non alors ça c'était
pas une bavure c'est est ce qu'on
appelle un drame
ils étaient des grades ont d'ailleurs
les idiots michel c'est dégradant pour
lui n'a peut-être mal vécue et non 90
ans on est face à autre chose et tout va
bien je les ai vus en laponie
ah non ça valait pas pudique ça va 100
ça vous vous dites oui moi j'ai dit oui
parce que d'abord il s'excuse très bien
elle dit que ça a sanctionné le cheonan
le show il est donc vous dites qu'en f1
a fait une erreur fait une erreur dans
la mesure où on ya une belle scène et à
jean pierre foucault il ya des gens
pourquoi tu vas aller filmer des
coulisses reste sur scène c'est une
fille sur scène on l'est on veut les
voir sur scène mais quelqu'un en
attendant il va les chercher et geof du
tuba regarde l'innovation ça alors
pourquoi rappelé gilles connaît que
c'était un concours de beauté
c'est pas la première fois qu'on voit
des cinq télévisions on en voit
régulièrement dans des documentaires sur
le lido ou sur des mannequins du défilé
de mannequins
la bande à l'aria demandé la peau elle a
réellement des blessures de même qu'à
qu'on monte dans d'autres documents tels
jean rien non plus apparemment les
mannequins on a un corps communs qui
esthétique c'est beau ça n'a rien de
dégradant par des musiques elle va avoir
du mal à s'en remettre
c'est rien mais c'est très très mal a
dit qu'il n'aimait pas mais n'a pas dit
que les led zoom assure le père du gil
oui bonsoir
bon ça non mais je trouve qu'il ya même
choquant je pense que si elle avait
gagné on n'aura pas fait un drame
merci ma soeur est absolument exact e
mans c'est vrai qu'elle est magnifique
après c'est pas parce qu'elle est belle
qu'elle a peut-être envie de se mettre à
poil exactement à la regarder
voilà ça y est les jolies et on la voit
très rarement début des jeux nous c'est
vrai qu'elle a changé ou là la vrai
qu'elle a alors on va voir ce qu'en
pensaient téléspectateurs juste oui à 60
%
oui non à 28% de pouvoir découlent il ya
soixante pour cent des téléspectateurs
qui pensent que tf1 a commis une faute
professionnelle c'est énorme
et bien quand il est en plus ces chars
fait souvent la réalité voilà - coup sur
l'année moi j'étais là je voulais
défendre tf1 mais comme je vois qu'à
70,7 nord ils sont vraiment fait de la
merde hein samedi ils ont fait de la
merde mais grave et j'étais là pour les
défendre
voilà merci